c'était sur l'élastique je pense propres
et dominer cache un secret il a 22 ans
sa mère et lui sont très proches les
deux parlent à plusieurs reprises d'une
condition médicale qui le tracasse pour
laquelle il refuse de se faire opérer
c'est comme s'il y avait quelque chose
en d'andreu qui me disait d'attendre
qu'ils équipes d'urgence comme un doute
justement il sera toujours temps
enfin quelques épisodes plus tard cette
mystérieuse conditions et finalement
révélé ni homme ni femme
il est intersection autrefois appelée
hermaphrodite
c'est arrivé par hasard l'auteur de la
série serge boucher explique que
dominique est inspiré de ses lectures
il a voulu en faire un personnage unique
qui est aux prises avec une dualité avec
le masculin et le féminin mais qu'il
assume entièrement j'ai pas envie de me
priver de ce plat de cette chance que
j'ai moi je lui fait dire ça j'ai la
chance d'avoir les deux sexes en moins
alors qu'on s'expose évident
beaucoup d'entre nous surtout pour les
personnes plus âgées avons vécu le
silence les personnes intersexe n'existe
pas que dans la fiction
janick bastien charlebois est l'une
d'entre elles quand j'étais plus jeune
j'avais des visites régulières chez le
médecin et il n'y a rien qui me faisait
souffrir dans mon corps mais il y avait
cette observation régulière et de la
table d'examination et apprend
progressivement coeur mais c'est juste
toi qui sera manche comme ça à l'hôpital
juste à faire regardez regardez l'organe
génital pas les autres utiliser acquise
parce que le médecin estime qu' un
problème avec mon corps
c'est à la naissance la plupart du temps
qui est détectée l'intersexuation un
bébé intersexe n'est ni fille ni garçon
il n'a que très rarement deux sexes
fonctionnel bien souvent son anatomie
est entre les deux pas typiquement
féminine ou masculine
c'est à dire dans les hauteurs à
l'hôpital de montréal pour enfants de 20
à 30 bébés qui naissent chaque année
développeront des caractéristiques
intersexe difficile de dire avec
certitude combien ils sont dans le monde
mais des travaux d'experts repris par
les nations unies estiment qu'il
pourrait former jusqu'à 1,7 pour cent de
la population
le gros défi c'est de rouvrir pour ces
personnes le docteur chauveau gauche
côtoient des jeunes intersexe il a
collaboré avec l'équipe de la série
fragile pour mieux les faire connaître
sans ont créé le problème des fois on
m'avait fait j'avais beaucoup et
terrorisé l'idée qu'on était une gagne 2
je vais y crut une gamme de pots beau
une gagne de personnes
quelque chose de très stigmatisés mais
sa vision a beaucoup évolué depuis des
années maintenant j'en ai qui milite
avec des gens de partout sur la planète
et stigmatise les corps intersexe pour
que le corps des personnes intersexe
soit accepté tel qu'il est nos corps
sont perçus comme des anomalies et il
faut que ça cesse la prévention c'est
donc un apperçu a beaucoup il va nous
falloir batailler basé principalement
sur les revendications des expériences
vécues par les passants interfax devenu
à qui on a fait des erreurs
pas nécessairement nous autres qui
pratiquent aujourd'hui mais dans la
passé il y avait les spécialistes qui
ont décidé pour la famille pour l'enfer
pendant des années les bébés avec une
ambiguïté génitales était opéré dès la
naissance
mais ces chirurgies sont de plus en plus
rare car leurs conséquences sont souvent
désastreuses
ces quelques années la vie à la
naissance
c'est presque comme on a créé un enfant
étranger
c'est cette année et si les chirurgies
irréversible avait été fait ça va
impliquer des problèmes au niveau
d'avant de la fertilité de la fonction
sexuelle et tout ce qu'ils gagnent et
écologique
janek avait échappé à ces chirurgies sa
mère à l'époque a refusé l'offre des
médecins mais sous une sorte de pression
sociale janick elle-même y a finalement
consenti
elle s'est fait opérer à 17 ans
aujourd'hui est ce que vous regrettez
oui au définitivement définitive c'est
ce que je veux absolument
tu peux vivre comme ça tout avis ceux ci
avaient un jeune qui voyait ça à l'écran
est réveillé quelque chose en tout cas
là tu es ou à trop faire du bien le spot
seul en fait la tv pour 101
janek le sait aujourd'hui qu'elle n'est
pas seule c'est sûr que numériquement on
est parent nombreux mais c'est pas parce
que quelque chose est rare que ça
signifie que c'est pas valide
ils nous ont peut pas revenir en arrière
on peut pas récupérer ce qu'on nous a
enlevé fait que la seule chose qu'on
peut faire c'est lutter pour que
d'autres personnes apprend à vivre parce
qu'on a vécu un combat pour que l'on
soit plus confortable avec la différence